this you know be bit puffy at the moment  what the bags under your eyes are  starting to dominate nation why are we  sadly for such blatant but Ollie I know  you can't what do you think  I think it's sensational join me and  starting a new existence within  ourselves  shite  oh you're lost I know about seas first  of all miss its worst of all  well you're a mesh I wasn't always like  this  [Music]  it's coming up for your night that's  Lucy  sometimes it feels like the world's gone  deaf  I can't tell if they can't hear me or  they're ignoring  [Music]  where are you so happy all the time  Jimmy stop spamming stop smiling I'm not  I can hope you will like more magic than  any mushroom ever text all there but I'm  in our heads the secrets of a perfect  existence  [Music]  let's never go out there  you